all right gary has arranged some sort of
a surprise it's not a mystery guest but
someone will now walk but he's just
gonna walk in there's no build-up and I
suppose we'll know who they are as soon
as we look I don't know Freddy and
Jackie said look somebody good let me
see I don't know him Wow Wow hey wait a
second I am totally totally amazed wait
a second it is Christy Todd Whitman the
greatest governor that ever listen let
me just say if you turn off that music
you will you mrs. Whitman you know
congratulations on all your success
thank you the first I ever heard of you
was I think you were on TV and I don't
even remember what show it was it was
like one of those public affairs shows
where you were debating a whole bunch of
different people running for you know
the Republican nomination right and I'm
watching I said you know she makes a lot
of sense there were a lot of guys there
who were just sort of like didn't seem
all that motivated to be governor and
then it was you so I was like kind of
diggin you then you got the nomination
and you were down in the polls and I
just said you know what I said I got to
do something here I got to say something
so I got involved and I believe we made
a difference and then it turned and then
everyone said yes she won but she's not
gonna do anything she's just a liar like
everyone else and she's not gonna cut
taxes and she's not gonna care about and
and you and you did it you I mean you
did something Democrats like it
Republicans like it you're intelligent
not everybody not everybody I have a
little presentation to make to you
though Howard
go ahead go during the campaign and you
certainly were helpful I can't tell you
how many of your listeners came up to me
during and after the campaign Thank You
governor but we talked about naming a
rest stop well I have to tell you that
things are a little different than what
we talked about yes all right pretty
much the same okay go ahead the New
Jersey Turnpike is you know is run by an
authority and they franchise out all
their rest stops so that wasn't gonna be
a possibility understood however we have
a very nice highway called I 295 and
that runs down and it did pitch your
other listening area 94.1 right between
k-rock and 94.1 right
this air this is the first rest stop on
the southbound area that we are
dedicating the Howard Stern the governor
did promised me that she would name a
rest stop after me it says Howard Stern
rest stop dedicated 1995 now governor
let me ask you something because I don't
understand what this means entirely does
that mean like the sign will say the
Howard Stern rest stop that's exactly
what the sign will look like it's made
out of cast aluminum
yes cement the first wrestler we're
dedicating to dedicating it to you it's
the first rest area the south wow this
is you have a documentation just like
the OJ trial what are you pointing out
here Wow and then Lane there the rest
areas yes this is truck stopping here
this is a picnic area it's gonna be wow
so you're saying oh that's exactly what
my monument will be exactly well isn't
this exciting I mean you know I gotta
tell you something you you are a
governor who keeps her word I mean you
did promise me a rest stop if you won
and you won't you really kept to it I
didn't even expect you ever to keep to
it she would come through this is very
exciting to me seriously I've always
dreamt of a rest stop that I would drive
by with my family and people could
relieve themselves while they see my
name I mean really that is great thanks
governor
I can't I can't thank you enough that's
really nice